ثم قال الرئيس اردوغان ان العمليات او
العمليه العسكريه التي يقوم بها لن تقتصر
على العمليات الجويه هل يعني ذلك ان
العمليه البريه قادمه حتما وقريبا برايك
بحسب هذا تصريح
انا لا اعتقد ذلك يعني هي نوعا ما من همم
ممكن اقول لها من باب
المطالبه يعني تركيا طبعا بعد العمليات
الارهابيه التي حصلت في اسطنبول ستطالب
باقصى حد ممكن ايضا النقطه الثانيه ستبقي
الضغوطات العسكريه والاعلاميه بشكل كبير
طبعا على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اولا
وثانيها ربما على روسيا بدرجه ابطال
الاردن وطبعا همم تستمر في الاستفاده في
ما حصل من اجل التخلص من الكثير من همم
لنقل القيادات العادات ما يقال ما يطال
يدها من حزب العمال الكردستاني سواء في
المنطقه العراقيه او المنطقه السوريه لذلك
اظن همم سيكون الثقافه عالي الان لكن
عمليه عسكريه انا اتوقع تحتاج الى ترتيبات
واضحه مع واشنطن لان الموضوع همم ليس بهذه
السهوله مع الرفض الكبير حتى الان لكل
طرفين باي عمليه عسكريه مع اختلاف التكتيك
يعني بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
هوليا يدعو الى ضبط النفس
التي ضربت اراضيها او العمليات ضربت
اراضيها وتتهم من خلالها حزب العمال
الكردستاني المجتمع الدولي يطالب برد
متناسب هل بالتالي هذا هو اقصى الضغط الذي
لا يمكن ان تقوم به انقره اليوم خصوصا
وانا المجتمع دولي مشغول ايضا بيكون ما
يجري في اوكرانيا
يجب تفسير هذا المنطق اظن بالنسبه يعني
كان بالرؤيه التركيه الى مسامرين المسار
الاول يعني انا لا اظن ان ستاخذ بعين
اعتبار كثير هذه
الطلبات لان تركيا تعتبر ان هناك نقاط
ارهابيه خطيره على حدودها لذلك هي وخصوصا
انها في دولتين السوريه والعراقيه لا
تمتلكان القدره العسكريه الكافيه
للقضاء على تلك البوعان المسار الثاني
بالنسبه
لتركيا همم اظن ان همم كما تفضلت هو
انشغال العالم لكن لابد من التنسيق لان
الوضع في الشمال السوري تحديدا اكثر
تعقيدا بكثير منه عليه في الشمال العراق
تحت الامريكيه لها مصالح واضحه مع قصد همم
روسيا لديها لصالح مع تركيا وتحاول ايجاد
صيغه التعاون بينها وبين اي بين انقره
ودمشق ايضا لا تريد همم انقر ايجاد يعني
تحول ال ال هذا الصراع زيادته لعوده
الخلاف مع دمشق بشكل كبير الان ربما
تستغل انشغال الروس في اوكرانيا وبالتالي
تريد ان تسرع فيها هذه العمليه في الشمال
السوري
كبيره لا تستطيع ان تقيم عده شبهات في عده
مناطق واظن دليل انها قامت في قصف مناطق
في ريف حلب وفي ريف ادلب انها مستعده
وجاهزه
وتنسيق همم يعني وفقا للمعلومات والقراءات
التي موجوده هنا في تركيا التنسيق بين
وزيرين دفاع عن تركيا والروسي حقيقه تنسيق
كبير كبير جدا ربما حتى تتضاربات هذه يكون
لديه علم مسبق لكن باوقات بسيطه لم يصح
عنها حتى الان الرئيس قال انه لم يتواصل
مع الرؤساء لكن هل لم تتواصل وزارات
الدفاع فيما بينها همم انا استمع ذلك شكرا
ايضا من اسطنبول